[Music]
how come Saito can have bodyguard
projections in limbo why doesn't anyone
else in the film have bodyguard
projections when they go to Limbo Taub
trusts the projection of his mischievous
dead wife to serve as the anchor for his
rope climb
this guy's their architect and he
doesn't know what the kick is the
architect gets every detail of Saito's
apartment correct down to the pillow gun
and the carpet stains but gets the
material at the carpet wrong this asian
kid is so important to the story he
doesn't get a name and then disappears
for the rest of the film there's
surprisingly little wind and noise when
standing underneath the helicopter I
have two things to say about this maze
one it doesn't look very hard two it's
actually impossible look Dean Dean I
think what invisible thing is she's
stepping over when she pulls the mirrors
Cobb knows he's going into Kobol
energies backyard and that they want him
dead but he has no escape plan in mind
except to run a white guy in mombasa
stands out like a black guy on Martha's
Vineyard oh there's someone yelling that
definitely means the guy we're tracing
went this way these bounty hunters are
terrible shots well this is beyond
convenient honestly why would a guy this
omniscient even need the services of
cobb and company hey look it's the
scientist from Avatar playing exactly
the same character Arthur feels the kick
from just his chair starting to fall
over but earlier Cobbs chair fell all
the way into the water before he felt
the kick the flight attendant pulls this
curtain then turns to get the briefcase
then turns to hand it to Arthur which
she's only able to do because the
curtain is now open again
this guy is standing right here firing
into an open rear window and he's not
hitting anything at all all this
screaming you would think he would have
at least one witness to support the
claim that he didn't kill his wife had
herself
declared singing by three different side
guys because that's not suspicious at
all so I ran but why didn't you just
wait for forensic science to prove that
your wife jumped from another building
all together and you know your
fingerprints aren't anywhere in the
ransacked hotel room if you can just
dream up bigger guns why the fuck don't
they leave this warehouse in a tank then
going in the water that's a kick band
tumbling over and over on its side not a
kick got it Arthur changes directions
between camera angles why do the rules
of gravity extend to the second level
dream but not the third level snow mode
shouldn't they've all gone flying off
the mountain into the air
Fisher partners up with Saito his
company's biggest and only true rival in
worldwide energy dominations and whom he
doesn't recognize the paradox thing is
cool but it only happens because the bad
guys in this
you cannot aim so you're saying in a
couple of minutes Arthur has an air
fight with his agent Smith dude
retrieves the charges arranges these
dudes in a stack obtains a bunch of wire
bundles up these idiots moves them down
the hall puts them in the elevator
places the charges on the elevator wire
blows the elevator wires places the
charge upon the elevator unties the
idiots and then blows the elevator all
in a couple of minutes just use the
defibrillator to revive him I'm pretty
sure that's not as easy as she makes it
sound now as cops projection and not a
real person so why does she go to limbo
after Cobb shoots her and how is she
able to kidnap Fisher before Cobb even
gets to limbo
so can they get out of the ocean
completely dry just moments later why is
he making a ransom deal with his own
projection he's basically just talking
to himself here it could be rescuing
Fisher considering the kick Arthur's
setting up in the hotel dream level
above and the fact that everyone gets
out of limbo by suicide is there even a
reason for this explosion or two seems
just like to blow up Ariadna forces two
people to die horrible falling dust from
a skyscraper when she could have just
shot them both in the head with the gun
she used to shoot Matt Cobb is basically
the same age but Saito super-old even
though they both entered limbo about the
same time US citizens don't get
passports stamped upon returning to the
country awesome happily ever after
hey did the COBOL engineering people
still wanna murder him okay let's talk
about totems why's cops told him just a
normal top but everyone else's totem is
weighted or hollowed out or otherwise
jacked up Arthur won't let Ariana touch
his way to die because only he knows
what number it's supposed to land on but
then everyone knows the top falls
there's nothing unique about the
behaviour of cops totem also why does it
totem show up in the dream in the first
place does the dreamer take it with them
subconsciously are they able to control
it and if they are why can't they
control all kinds of others with their
minds while they're in dreams why do
they even have to be behind the wheel of
a car to make it drive Saito touches
cops totem which is a no-no but then
that was in limbo so is that bad why do
the totems even have to be there inside
the dreams like why can't the method for
determining your own realities be the
simple fact you have a totem in your
pocket just don't take the totem into
the dream do I have a totem in my pocket
right now hmm
no still dreaming so you're not gonna
tell us whether he's dreaming or not
you're just gonna let that top spin and
make it wobble a bit and tease us with a
cut to black you brilliant mother
man I can't wait to see Nolan's new
Batman well what the is this